lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
convertir esta cantidad de kilómetros en
metros y centímetros voy a empezar con
dos kilómetros pero te invito a que
primero pongas pausa en el vídeo y
pruebes hacerlo por tu cuenta lo que
sabemos es que kilómetros literalmente
significa 1000 metros así es que esto
quiere decir dos veces mil metros o dos
por mil metros vamos a escribirlo aquí
dos por mil que es igual a 2000
metros 2000 metros si queremos convertir
11 kilómetros en metros es lo mismo 11
km recordamos que kilo quiere decir 1000
kilómetros son 1000 metros de tal manera
que 11 kilómetros equivalen a 11 por mil
que es igual a 11 mil metros ahora vamos
a convertir estas distancias en
centímetros y aquí tenemos que recordar
que un metro equivale a 100 centímetros
déjame escribir eso un metro
equivale a 100 centímetros y eso es
porque el prefijo sentí quiere decir 100
otra manera de ver esto es que un
centímetro equivale a un centésimo de
metro pero aquí tenemos una cierta
cantidad de metros y cada uno de esos va
a ser equivalente a 100 centímetros de
tal manera que si aquí tenemos 2 mil
metros dos mil metros van a ser
equivalentes a veamos si cada metro es
equivalente a 100 centímetros hay que
multiplicar 2000 por 100 para obtener la
cantidad
y esto cuánto nos da bueno dos mil
serían dos y los tres ceros del mil
vamos a poner los dos mil ahora al
multiplicar por diez recuerda que
agregamos un cero y al multiplicar por
cien tendremos que agregar dos ceros
entonces dos mil por cien equivale a
agregar dos ceros después del 2000 2000
y 20 es decir dos kilómetros equivalen a
doscientos mil centímetros bien hagamos
lo mismo por acá ya sabemos que 11
kilómetros son 11 mil metros y de nueva
cuenta te invito a que pongas pausa en
el vídeo y conviértase sus centímetros
es la misma idea tenemos 11 mil metros y
cada uno de esos es equivalente a 100
centímetros y esto es igual a veamos 11
y 1 2 3 4 5 0 2 1 2 3 4 5 ceros esto es
igual a
1.100.000 centímetros